speaking of what you're talking about
taking a darker turn
how does a writer know they're getting
notes from let's say a saboteur in some
sense and maybe it's not
that they're trying to really hold them
down maybe they're afraid they don't
want them to succeed or whatever it is
you know you have the cheerleader your
family maybe your friends
but there are also people that won't be
truthful and the notes are giving you
and it's a
darker angle that's a great question
because there's a lot of competition and
a lot of jealousy sometimes
among writers particularly in writer's
groups and
and it is important to to weed out the
people who
could be potentially sabotaging a
project but
i would say you know if if you're
getting notes that
sound like they are first of all
attacking the writer
um those should be thrown out with you
know
across the board those are not helpful
in any way
um and then if it's a note that attacks
the
that attacks the project but is given in
a way
that is trying to
um destroy rather than build up
that's not going to be helpful either
and and in general
you know even a hard note a heart a note
that is hard to hear
there is some element of hope in that
note um
for the sake of getting better and
growing and so you know if you take the
metaphor of pruning
a lot of notes are about pruning things
back and clearing things away
um but that's only for the new good
things to grow stronger and better yeah
i i've uh we've both received just awful
notes and i
and in terms of somebody using the notes
process in a destructive way one time i
had a producer who
uh we had we had tension on a project
and she wanted to take me down a peg and
i
i kind of felt that and she you know she
said as much but
so then on a script she said uh what's
this
this line in the script here what is
that and i said well that's you know
it's a joke it leads into the scene
and she said a joke a joke well it's not
funny and you're not funny you know
so just take everything out of the
script that you think is funny because
that'll save me time
all right now this is a great example of
somebody who's now moved beyond the
notes process
into trying to rein in the writer or
reigning you know whatever by um you
know
really just kicking somebody in the gut
and uh
when you get when you hear something
like that you know and you can just kind
of tell
you know this is went right to the
personal uh
just dismiss it there's nothing there uh
for you to hear
uh and uh we i can only say that in the
strongest terms because it can be
debilitating to a writer that kind of
personal
uh attack and and you need to be away
from that person if you can i mean if
they if they're
if they're your boss on the project
their producer you're kind of stuck with
them and you just got to find a way to
cope but
thank goodness every project is
temporary but for us that would be that
person if somebody did that in a writing
group they're out
yeah you know that's how serious it is
uh you need to just sever your
connection with somebody who goes after
you like that
because it's just as too hard as it is
to do this stuff without somebody
really uh turning uh you know your
efforts at
becoming a professional into a personal
uh attack and uh
you just you got to fortify yourself so
constructive criticism with
a ray of hope that that's how you would
know that it's actually
useful and not true someone really
trying to wound someone
yeah and it's a criticism you know i
mean sometimes it becomes obvious that
the writer has an issue when we're
working with them like the mother issue
you know kind of thing
but we don't go there really unless
we're invited to
and that's another thing you know when
it moves into the personal the writer
really needs to be the one to say to you
you know
i wonder if i have mother issues and i
can't do this story
but for us to make that jump it's very
unprofessional you know we're there
talking about
when we read this scene this is where it
leaves us it's not bringing us where it
needs to
and that's pretty much the best kind of
feedback for a writer to get so
so yeah any kind of personal stuff uh it
now you've moved out of the realm of
professionalism and
and we're very big on this is a
profession and a craft and you need to
have professional standards of behavior
that's one of the whole third part of
notes to screenwriters is about that
because we've seen too many people fail
uh because they you know they it
this is storytelling it's about the
deepest human things in you and it's
very easy
to uh let that human stuff kind of
you know spill into the profession the
professional side but you've got to keep
them separate
you